now because I I feel like you had like a
you were you were kind of like dabbling
a bit into Spanish [ __ ] right trying to
make more like uh Spanglish yeah kind of
I feel like you were kind of trying to
make more records that weren't
necessarily
maybe what your core fan base would
expect from you for a while that was
like a lot of external pressures for
those types of Records yeah yeah so you
know I had to kind of take it back a
little bit I feel like when you have
like a I feel like that you you have you
busted a hard left
I feel like if you're gonna go there you
got to make it a gradual left well you
know I was getting pressure man like it
was one of those things like yo we're
gonna open a marketing budget you're
like yo you're Hispanic you speak
Spanish what are you doing that was
literally that's literally I know what
the conversation was oh you probably
have it a lot with oh for sure yeah I
know the combo they wanted to take you
in you got to do records of Wisin Yandel
God bless amazing artists but like it
doesn't really make sense with Emilio
it's you just got to get there like
gradually I'm just not a [ __ ] I don't
do it like a tongue I don't do right I
think like at the end of the day like
I think your fans have a certain like
love for some of the stuff you do it's
very transparent it's very personal it's
very lyric driven and I feel like some
of the stuff I was hearing from you I
was like oh dude it wasn't this is
interesting this is a hard left well it
was like we were trying to mix the two
right so I've always made records about
girls I've always done like breakup
records and stuff but like why don't we
put it on like a Latin Rhythm right okay
cool I mean I'm Latino I like that those
type of Records it's cool you know I've
been making records for a while so like
it's no harm in experimenting yeah it
worked I mean listen how did those
records do they did all right like did
you did you notice like it open your fan
base and or did it also piss off your
regular fan base a little well I think
what I did which was smart and just not
even deliberate but just what I've
always done is just I've always like
stayed lyrical even in those spaces of
course yeah yeah so I mean you're a
[ __ ] beast so it's like you can't
help but be incredible at rapping thank
you hey that's I appreciate that thank
you yeah it's our it's our it's like not
like people who rap as good as you it's
it's like no matter what you're gonna do
it's gonna be dope in terms of like the
lyricism you know yeah so I think you
know it satisfied people a little bit
and I was still trying to give my my
core
records yeah you know like we we tried
to walk the line and I still you know
like I don't think it was inauthentic to
me as a human being because like I like
girls and kids of course maybe from a
marketing standpoint it could have been
done a little bit more deliberately so
would you say the new stuff coming out
is a little bit more like kind of back
to like what got you here type [ __ ] well
it's like well obviously you put a
mixtape out which is very [ __ ] you
know I just wanted a rap bro that's what
I mean like that's very vintage of you
yeah and it was it wasn't really a lot
of thought put into it which is right
which is great sometimes that's the best
thing you just don't man I'm sure you've
been through this just overthinking your
music [ __ ] can be sometimes the worst
it's finished it's better than perfect
yeah all the time bro and it's like when
you have all these people like yo we're
gonna open this is a smash we're gonna
do this this and this like from the
labels or whatever and you're trying to
deliver and then they never deliver on
their promises or whatever
it it muddies the waters